Вони розшукують останки загиблих у Східній Україні.
Олексій Юков - один з волонтерів гуманітарної місії "Чорний Тюльпан".
Це єдина в Україні громадська ініціатива,
яка займається пошуком зниклих на цій війні:
і цивільних, і військових.
За неповні три роки віднайшли тіла понад 600 загиблих,
які повернули рідним та перепоховали. Ще від 300 до 1500 -
досі зниклі безвісти.
- Бачиш, тут зверху на ньому була тканина якась,
як ватинна… зверху на камуфляжі, бачиш?
- Тобто залишки покриття?
- Так, покриття.
Або його загорнули в це, або накрили.
Справа в тому, що займаючись цим
упродовж трьох років, ти постійно стикаєшся
з ситуаціями трагедії людей.
Таких же людей, як і ти сам. І таких же родин,
які втратили своїх близьких і рідних.
І хочеш ти чи ні, ти пропускаєш через себе їхній біль,
їхню трагедію.
Коли бойовики захопили його рідний Слов'янськ,
Юков розпочав пошукові роботи тіл загиблих –
незалежно від того, на чиєму боці вони воювали.
І це мало не коштувало йому життя.
Мене звинуватили у зраді батьківщини. Мене арештували.
Протримали 5 годин в колишній будівлі СБУ,
після чого виголосили смертний вирок, який був підписаний.
була спроба мене вивести на "зеленку" і розстріляти,
як і того чоловіка, якого вбили до мене,
чиє тіло лежало поруч.
Але в останню мить друзі визволили Олексія з полону сепаратистів.
Далі він переховувався.
Коли ж Збройні сили України повернули контроль
над цією частиною Донецької області,
чоловік продовжив пошуки тіл загиблих.
Буквально за п'ятдесят кілометрів звідси гримлять бої.
На цій території величезна кілька загиблих і зниклих безвісти.
Тому ми не можемо сказати, що війна закінчилася.
Війна не закінчиться, поки не знайдуть
та не перепоховають усіх до останнього солдата.
Окрім участі у пошуковій місії "Чорний Тюльпан"
Юков навчає молодь у Слов'янську бойовому мистецтву.
Для нього це – значно більше, ніж просто кікбоксинг.
Річ у тім, що кожен з нас в "Чорному Тюльпані" отримує хоч незначну,
але все ж психологічну травму.
І, можна сказати, весь негатив я скидаю тут, на тренуваннях,
займаючись на "грушах", на "лапах", тренуючи інших.
Водночас, можна сказати, я сам собі роблю часткову психологічну реабілітацію
від того стресу, який отримую.
Наступного дня Юков знову вирушає на пошуки.
Разом з іншими волонтерами він перевіряє інформацію
про зниклого бойовика.